Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Partiamo con una domanda:
il libro avrà un futuro?
E in particolare,
il libro dei libri,
la Bibbia, avrà un futuro?
Questa domanda si pone
in questo inizio del XXI secolo,
caratterizzato da una drammatica
guerra dei media.
Abbiamo uno scontro in atto
tra la stampa e i media digitali,
gli e-book e i tablet contro i libri;
l'Encyclopédie di Diderot
surclassata dal suo alias digitale
e partecipativo, Wikipedia;
giornali e magazine
aggrediti e minacciati
dai motori di ricerca.
È sotto gli occhi di tutti,
questo conflitto,
e può portare a una vera e propria
apocalisse del libro.
Ma tornando alla domanda,
questa apocalisse potrà portare con sé
anche il più importante libro, la Bibbia,
oppure no?
Per dare una risposta,
torniamo indietro nella storia
e dall'Apocalisse del libro
passiamo alla Genesi.
L'origine della Bibbia.
Siamo sul Sinai nel II millennio A.C.,
dove si combatte
la prima grande guerra dei media,
che vede contrapporsi
l'alfabeto al geroglifico.
In questa guerra,
che vediamo rappresentata
con Mosè che alza le tavole,
si colloca anche l'origine della Bibbia,
che vedremo coincide
con l'invenzione dell'alfabeto.
Dice il libro dell'Esodo,
"Le tavole erano opera di Dio,
la scrittura era scrittura di Dio
scolpita sulle tavole".
È la prima volta che, nella Bibbia,
si parla di scrittura:
i patriarchi precedenti
si esprimevano, diciamo, in forma orale;
qui, invece, ecco che compare
sulle tavole la scrittura.
Cosa ci dice l'archeologia?
L'archeologia dice che, in effetti,
l'alfabeto nasce sul Sinai
e qui noi dobbiamo confutare quello che
normalmente è scritto sui libri di testo,
cioè che i fenici
hanno inventato l'alfabeto.
Non è vero,
l'alfabeto è stato introdotto sul Sinai.
Guardate questi segni:
a sinistra c'è proprio il nome di Dio,
scritto in alfabeto protosinaitico
e la cosa singolare
è che le lettere sono proprio
dei segni visivi,
un toro in particolare.
Qui sulla destra vediamo
l'evoluzione della tecnica alfabetica:
dal segno visibile di un ideogramma,
il segno del toro,
si arriva, attraverso
una serie di deformazioni,
a una lettera, la nostra lettera A.
In realtà, la cosa interessante -
e qui c'è un'indagine
anche un po' simbolica -
la prima lettera significa toro, bue.
E in effetti è l'immagine di un bue.
Ma la testimonianza
drammatica del conflitto
sta proprio nella prima dichiarazione
che la scrittura di Dio fa:
"Non ti farai idolo né immagine alcuna".
Ed è proprio il primo comandamento,
che proibisce le immagini.
Siamo nel contesto
di una drammatica contesa
tra la cultura visiva
e la cultura fonetica.
Questa scena si compie con l'atto finale:
l'uccisione del vitello,
la distruzione del segno visivo.
Perché la lettera nasca
deve morire l'immagine.
E vediamo in questo filmato
come ciò accade:
proprio con la distruzione dell'idolo,
il vitello d'oro, da parte di Mosè.
(Filmato)
(Musica)
La distruzione fisica dell'idolo
coincide, nella nostra psiche,
con l'eliminazione della cultura visiva
che ha accompagnato l'uomo
per decine di migliaia di anni.
Da quel momento nasce l'Occidente,
nasce in un certo senso
la coscienza rispetto all'inconscio,
nasce la razionalità rispetto al mito.
Questa storia si può esprimere
anche in altre forme.
Vediamo un'altra modalità:
si passa dall'Egitto al Sinai,
poi attraverso la Fenicia, Grecia, Roma,
Alef diventa Alfa,
lettera greca, poi diventa A.
Qui si destina l'Occidente.
In sostanza l'alfabeto è la base,
il codice che struttura
la cultura ebraica,
anche islamica in realtà,
la filosofia greca
e quindi tutta la nostra civiltà,
che ancora oggi studia alfabeticamente.
La nostra esperienza cognitiva
è sostanzialmente alfabetica
da circa 3.000 anni.
Vediamo, da un punto di vista geografico,
come è avvenuto questo passaggio
(Filmato)
(Musica)
dal geroglifico alla lettera semitica,
alla lettera alfabetica in Grecia.
Questo tipo di passaggio
in realtà, appunto,
si basa sul riepilogo fondamentale
di una guerra che c'è stata,
ma non è l'unica
che la Bibbia ha affrontato.
In questo caso, avete visto,
la Bibbia ha vinto,
cioè la nuova scrittura si è imposta
sulla civiltà precedente,
l'ideogramma, il geroglifico.
In realtà, dopo questa guerra
ce ne sono state altre,
in particolare l'era cristiana
vede un capovolgimento di fronte,
perché Dio, incarnato e visibile,
diventa anche irrappresentabile,
quindi dopo un conflitto
nell'VIII secolo, dell'iconoclastia,
dove ci fu una disputa:
si può o no usare le immagini
per la conoscenza sacra?
La risposta fu sì,
e nacque una stagione incredibile
che l'Italia ha conosciuto
in modo straordinario,
la stagione della Bibbia per immagini,
quindi le cattedrali,
l'arte sacra, la miniatura.
Ecco Lutero, un altro capovolgimento;
e quindi con la stampa
c'è la rivincita dell'alfabeto.
Siamo di fronte all'Era Digitale.
Cosa succederà?
Rivediamo questo, rapidamente,
in un'altra forma.
Questa è una rappresentazione
originale della cultura umana,
attraverso due fasce fondamentali:
il codice iconico e il codice alfabetico.
50.000 A.C., gli idoli,
le scritture rupestri,
ma ecco che arriva Mosè;
l'alfabeto, i codici
destinano poi la Bibbia ebraico-cristiana;
successivamente, di nuovo,
c'è un conflitto,
stavolta contro il mito in Grecia,
da cui nasce la filosofia occidentale.
Vedete, la cultura dal contesto iconico
passa al contesto alfabetico;
il Corano resta pienamente
in contesto alfabetico,
pensate alla proibizione delle immagini
che ancora oggi è oggetto di dispute,
le vignette sono una profanazione
del Primo Comandamento
anche per gli islamici.
Avviene, nell'VIII secolo,
un conflitto, di nuovo,
che riporta invece i codici
nel contesto visivo:
miniature, arte sacra, cattedrali.
Di nuovo un conflitto:
la stampa, scissione, scisma d'Occidente,
Lutero, Gutenberg, la stampa.
Oggi dove siamo?
E qui entriamo nella "pars
construens" dell'intervento,
cioè come può essere immaginato
il prossimo libro,
e la prossima Bibbia quindi.
Abbiamo visto che analizzando
la storia della Bibbia,
non è solo un libro.
La Bibbia precede il libro,
ed è stata rappresentata e letta
anche come arte sacra,
miniatura, gregoriano,
forme liturgiche, cattedrali.
Quindi, e qui c'è
un altro guru del nostro tempo -
come dice Steve Jobs, "Ipad is iconic",
cioè questi strumenti sono iconici:
l'immagine torna
ad essere prevalente, centrale.
Quindi perché non riscoprire
una tradizione fondamentale medioevale,
che è la Biblia Pauperum.
Nell'epoca in cui l'alfabeto
era passato in secondo piano,
nelle nostre cattedrali
si leggeva la Bibbia per immagini.
La "Bibbia dei Poveri"
è una tradizione, molto consolidata,
di alfabetizzazione cognitiva della Bibbia
attraverso le immagini.
Ma un altro concetto importante,
che deriva dalla evoluzione
del libro elettronico,
è il libro aumentato.
Da questo punto di vista,
possiamo riferirci ad un altro referente,
cioè le miniature.
Cos'era la miniatura?
In un contesto in cui
non esisteva la stampa,
il libro era molto prezioso:
avveniva un forte arricchimento,
aumento del libro
attraverso immagini, simboli, decorazioni,
che trasformavano questo oggetto
in qualcosa di completamente diverso
rispetto a quello che oggi è
un libro stampato.
E perché non pensare
ad una miniatura digitale,
quindi alla possibilità
che dopo l'epoca della stampa
si ritorni a un libro aumentato
con una miniatura digitale
che possa arricchire la lettura
con altri contesti e, diciamo, media.
Un altro aspetto.
Oggi qual è l'alfabeto universale?
Non quello latino, non quello cirillico,
ma è l'icona.
Da quando, nei computer,
è stata introdotta
l'interfaccia uomo-macchina
della cosiddetta scrivania,
le icone sono diventate
l'unico vero alfabeto universale,
condiviso da arabi, cinesi, occidentali.
Ma anche qui c'è una risposta:
esiste un codice simbolico nella Bibbia?
E quindi, il simbolo
può tornare a diventare
una interfaccia grafica del testo?
Quindi indici simbolici, ad esempio,
e non alfabetici.
La scrittura cinese
è un indice simbolico, ad esempio,
rispetto alla nostra
che ha un ordine alfabetico.
Un altro aspetto fondamentale:
qual è il media più ricco, oggi,
nel settore digitale?
Sono i giochi, i videogiochi.
Hanno superato il cinema per fatturato,
sono pervasivi, lo vedete,
soprattutto presso le giovani generazioni.
Ma è pensabile una
"gamification" della Bibbia?
Intanto, che implicazioni ci sono?
Come diceva Cicerone,
"La memoria può essere aiutata
attraverso la simulazione virtuale".
Diceva Cicerone: "La memoria artificiale
è costituita da luoghi e immagini",
come i videogiochi: luoghi e immagini.
Il tutto vivibile in modo attivo.
Ma in fondo anche la Bibbia, nel Medioevo,
con i gargoyle, con le dispute filosofiche
con tutta una serie di esperienze,
aveva una componente di ludicità;
e quindi perché non può essere vero,
come diceva in un Ted Talk Jessy Schell,
che i giochi diventino un medium
per la vita di ogni giorno?
E quindi, gamificare anche il libro
sicuramente sarà una strada
che verrà percorsa.
Il libro non è più bidimensionale:
diventa tridimensionale o immersivo.
Quindi è possibile che il libro
sia intorno a noi,
come una sfera che ci circonda
Applicato al terreno storico,
e della Bibbia in particolare,
questo diventa uno "stargate",
una sorta di macchina del tempo
che ci può portare
al tempo di Abramo, Mosè e Cristo
e quindi un altro modo ulteriore
di pensare a un futuro della Bibbia.
Oppure, in modo ancora diverso,
il libro come guida sul luogo,
pensata a una visita
dei luoghi della Bibbia,
attraverso una guida
che ci consente di immergerci
in quello che era incontrare la Bibbia
nei luoghi della Bibbia.
Questo, ad esempio,
è molto plausibile realizzarlo,
con le tecnologie della realtà aumentata.
Abbiamo fatto un percorso,
questo percorso ci ha portato
ad esplorare cos'è un libro elettronico,
in che modo può evolvere
e in che modo può essere applicato
a un contesto specifico,
come quello della Bibbia.
L'ultimo aspetto rilevante
riguarda la componente sociale.
"Social reading" è un'espressione,
che soprattutto nel contesto Amazon
ma anche in altri contesti,
indica il fatto che oggi
la lettura è condivisa.
Cioè, noi possiamo condividere
con altre persone quello che leggiamo,
lo possiamo commentare,
lo possiamo inviare
e questo è un aspetto distintivo
del libro elettronico
e della pagina elettronica.
Ma se noi guardiamo, la parola Chiesa
vuol dire "community",
quindi la condivisione attorno al testo
è sempre stata un fenomeno fondamentale;
e allora ecco che la Bibbia, e il libro,
possono tornare ad essere un social media.
E qui concludo:
sostanzialmente direi di sì,
questo percorso ci porta a pensare
che la Bibbia e il libro
avranno un futuro,
e questo futuro sarà digitale.
Grazie.
(Applausi)